Darren how are you this morning I'm good
how are you Dan I'm spectacular all
right uh why now and where we go in with
these uh at with advertising on jerseys
it would have happened sooner actually
in 2011 uh that's when Adam Silver
obviously wasn't Commissioner at the
time kind of broach the subject and said
hey you know it's worth a hundred
million dollars a year us and it slowed
down by five years only because with the
next TV deal which is obviously signed
last year coming up for the the
following starting next year uh the the
TV partners Turner and an ESPN had at
least expressed some skepticism about
what happens if someone who doesn't
advertise with us uses putting an ad on
the Jersey or putting their logo on a
jersey as a way to get around us and if
we're paying billions of dollars that's
not good so that kind of slowed things
down a little bit and then after the
deal was done um you know I think that
they said this is not really that big of
a deal um and uh and they were able to
move forward of course fans still think
this is very much a big deal and you
know you can go back to when naming
rights started on baseball stadiums or
whatever I mean even as late as you know
two thousand when the when the Tigers
moved to their new stadium and speak it
called Comerica Park and people come out
saying not only am I not going to a
tigers game I'm withdrawing my money
from comerica bank I'm livid and that's
just how it is I mean that's that's it
people have to get used to it I think
it's gonna be the same thing here what
will the jerseys look like it can be a
two and a half by two and a half inch
patch there is no exception to that is
one was who the Kia logo for the old
yeah yes that Kiki logo was a little bit
bigger um but yes it's going to be that
small um and uh one sponsorship
evaluation company says you see in any
in that one particular all obviously the
only time that we've we've been able to
see it but in that one particular game
there was
four minutes and 29 seconds where you
clearly saw kiya throughout the entire
all-star game but it will be the nike
jersey nike logo the swoosh on one side
and that's going to be the first time
and what's so crazy about this is that
David Stern for so long even though
adidas did the deal that they did with
how much money they paid David Stern
kept saying no absolutely not no adidas
logo on the Jersey so when Nike uh in
1718 when Nike becomes the partner to be
the first time that even in apparel
sponsor has their logo on and then on
the other side will be that will be that
patch and silver says you know he's
still estimating about a hundred million
dollars a year I think that's
conservative the league asked the teams
to submit kind of estimates as to how
much they would make potentially and i
was told that when you add it all up
it's in between 120 180 million dollars
a year well you're double-dipping you're
getting nike money and you're gonna get
a sponsorship as well so I one of the
compromises they did make was and this
was this this this happened late one of
the compromises they did make was that
the logos will not be on the nike will
but the other logo that they're selling
will not be on the retail version of the
jerseys at least that nike puts out if
if a team wants to put special ones in
the team store they can do so but i
think that was one of the compromises
okay but soccer started this way in the
eighties yeah yeah and I heard you guys
just talking about it yes and and you
even look at the in the WNBA jerseys
which you know that started in 2009 as a
little you know lifelock on a Phoenix
Mercury jersey and other the Phoenix
life locks and it's just what it is
that's how it's changed I'm I'm not I'm
not sure it's gonna it's going to be
that way but obviously things changed
when the money gets greater okay
speaking of which the NFL can you see
the NFL like they're kicking the tires
on this as well they want to see how
this goes but the NFL which sells
everything why wouldn't they go go
you you you would think and now the NFL
did what the NBA didn't which was years
ago they decided to put the cell will
allow teams to sell the logos on the
practice jerseys that didn't really turn
out to be any sort of experiment at all
because the only time you see a logo on
a practice jersey is when there's a
newscast and that newscast is from a
network that doesn't have NFL rights and
all they do is show highlights of what
happened at practice because they can't
show games I mean the value of that is
so infinitesimally doesn't even it
didn't it didn't even serve as a test
but uh but ya know I I would not be
comfortable saying that you know any
league is uh is is safe from this and I
think people will I think people get
comfortable with it I think they will
there will be some logos that are more
uncomfortable than others I mean I think
we're so used to seeing the cokes in the
Pepsi's and even you know if you look at
the the soccer it's based on how weird
it is and it's just like stadium naming
rights if it's a weird company name or a
weird logo we tend to feel dirtier about
it I think it's going to be the same
case here so the godaddy Red Sox are yet
i'm not sure what the but yeah and then
add there's also going to be some
coolness factor to some of them i mean
on the flip side i mean i i'm sure a lot
of people would love to see the
in-and-out logo on the lakers but that
was probably bad team but the latter
pick a team in california uh Kobe's
final game memorabilia pretty big
numbers there yeah they sold 1.2 million
dollars worth of Kobe stuff in the arena
staple center uh which is a record on a
single night breaking uh what is this is
a 2007-2008 uh uh was it led zeppelin in
london selling a million dollars worth
of stuff i mean it breaks the all-time
record I've never seen anything like it
in terms of you go into a team store and
it's all one players never ever been
that way I mean even with the Yankees
and Jeter and you know you by Yankee
stuff you basically couldn't buy any
Lakers
not like anyone would want to at this
point in the season but but it was
amazing in the prices were just
outrageous and and even though they were
so outrageous I think they still
mispriced it in some cases made it too
low there was a snakeskin texture type
Jersey that was selling for eight
hundred twenty four dollars it came in a
box and I saw a guy walk in and he said
how many do you have left and they said
20 and he said I'll take them all 824
dollars and you can bet easy to slip
those for 1,500 2,000 apiece on now that
they're sold out and they're never
making them again he just cornered the
market good to talk to you Darren thank
you for joining us always great to catch
up then all right Darren Rovell ESPN
sports business reporter the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience